[Music]
i like to break down the dna
of a song to show you where it came from
in the case of nice for what drake
sampling lauren hill
when lauren hill is sampling wu-tang
clans which is gladys knight
covering a barbara streisand song it's a
meta rabbit hole
sometimes you gotta let people in on the
fun and there's nothing more fun
than the discovery of oh i know that
song that's where that comes from
to be honest with you not drumming in
the world's funkiest group
not the book writing not being on late
night television
my first love is records i've been
listening and analyzing records since
the age of five
i've never shared the method to my
madness or my secrets or my creative
process
in dj until right now
in my master class i will teach you how
to curate
the perfect playlist how to search for
music how to figure out where it belongs
and then i want to teach you how to
utilize it by being an effective dj
so if i decide i need an extra kick drum
i can press
when the kick drum occurs like right
here
if you have any relationship with music
this class is for you
that sort of rhythm has not failed me
yet it's rhythmic
it's sexy it makes everyone want to get
on the dance floor and just party
you can scratch you can mix you can cut
you could be shovel take these tools
and build something of your own loving
music
and learning how to find it and
appreciate it and use it to find effect
that's what i want to teach you
i'm questlove and this is my master
[Music]
class
okay
don't stop
[Music]
okay